do you guys hear that
some kind of like scratching
there
what is that
is that me is that me
that's a helicopter outside i'm a
dumbass welcome to feed vid live this is
game about finding a live stream
where something horrible happens
like
cruise missile
like you can put in like a
so
hi
you watch twitch do you like live
streams what if something went wrong
during one of those live streams that's
what this is here's your name
bam
oh
epic jake cries on stream mental
breakdown clips you thank you
angel ave at the gym gamma gamer swatted
mr johnster destroys a keyboard i love
this creepy man stalks kitty 360 during
irl stream tokyo vlogs mugged in broad
daylight hitting the slots
what
addressing the drama hot tub stream
starting soon untitled stream is that
what i'm
ah this viewer thank you
oh no
uh
hello
huh
oh wow
um
okay
oh hi hello xbx hello catherine
i don't know
looks good though
ah
the old bathroom stall live stream this
is like a preamble to bob's uh
or uh wade's saga of cleaning bathroom
bob and wade saga of cleaning bathroom
did anyone else randomly get gifted a
sub so what exactly are we looking at
it's a bathroom stall with a toilet a
door and a drain
oh
drain
that's fun
that's fun wait is there something in
the drain
this is fun this is cool the cover is
screwed shut oh my god it's like an
escape room
but text game this is nuts
wait a
minute check the toilet
i'm
oh this is so crazy
this concept
someone could actually do a live stream
open the lid
of this oh what is that oh it's a
screwdriver i thought it was a fish this
is so
smart oh my god
oh
god
this is crazy
this is so
this is nuts i love this
oh this is so fun
okay we got a key
yeah a key
yeah take the key
stupid
maybe i shouldn't be so mean you're
gonna stare at that hole all day or are
you gonna kiss it
all right fine go back that door looks
kinda
[Music]
funny though
omg i'm such a fan
i'm literally shaking and crying right
rn
oh what is that
i'm screaming
use the key
oh hate that
oh hate this
now this is content pockets
ah this is uh
this is uh interesting
there's something behind us what do you
mean
what's
behind us
oh
there's someone there
you're right
oh my god look out
holy [ __ ] is there writing on the sink
oh
wow
we got a penis a bull horns and a bow
and arrow acm
oh
thanks that's helpful how'd you do that
that functionality ain't there
but i appreciate it but big preach okay
maybe look
look for the cryptid in the corner
all right fine then uh
what about the door
i see
looks like one of those doors that needs
a code thanks tri-state gamer you got
good eyes uh go back and check for them
monster standing right behind you
big ass monster
dumbass
around stupid
oh it's gone
oh
gotta poop
go in the urinal
ah
yes suey
uc
thanks xpx
thanks man okay so we've got cam ius
uh check the other stall okay what is
the spell
uh
we got come
i as come
come i as
oh no more letters so we got
r-l-o-i-u-s-a-c-m
slory oh wait no the letters are
pertaining to this so we got an m
looking thing so that's o
bull o c
u
o c u
l o c u l
i o c l u r o c l u i
a chloe
it's a chloe
there's a chloe right there
door dumbass check the door check the
door
dummy
it's a clue
a chloe
oh right
the numbers pro okay i haven't okay
a b c d e f g h i
a j h
m n o five five one
a b c d f g h i j k l
four stop bobbing around so much u
that's eight
and then i
a b c d f g h i
three
five one five three
you got it buddy
no
i'm losing viewers i'm
viewers are flooding away from me did i
not do that right
okay
oh mno that
oh my god what was it
what was that
okay anyway let me try this again i love
this i love this by the way uh how about
we go
the first
stall i know that just goes to that
stall
look in the toilet
take a piss
poop
your pants
wipe your ass
wipe
your ass
uh flush
eat a dick
eat my dick
eat your dick
eat he she we them they are
dick uh urinal
sorry i spoke spanish for a second there
unless i'm being incredibly dumb about
this and i've actually gotten everything
wrong
so it's m bull equals so m is
o
c o c let me type it out o c o c
equals u
o c u
l
a cooly
oculi
uh
right
i'm
dumb
so it's
five
one
eight
four
three
five one eight four three
no
is that what i said before five one
one five one eight four three
oh
i didn't need to turn it into numbers i
just needed to put in
oculi
oh
oh well that's not good
good thing i got that on the first try
and i'm so smart what is that
oh just got raided by carl j lmao oh wow
that's a lot of viewers
not sure is that a body
is that a body
holy [ __ ]
i'm shaking and crying oren
a
shake its hand
touch it
remove the blanket
kiss the hand
yeah i don't think we want to do that
huh all right what do we have is a
locker and a door
what about the locker
this is what would happen if you guys
actually had control
twitch plays markiplier here ah another
code another code eh
yeah you right
you big smart
me big smarter
look at wall
me look at wall
interesting
could the code be
oh
wait these are all these are all all
over the place
i think i've seen something like this in
math class magic squares right each row
column and both diagonals have the same
sum
i also
thought that yeah
i'm glad we all came to the same
conclusion and have the same level of
intelligence okay so that diagonal is
eight five two that's 15. so all these
must equal 15 so two must be
one must be three
six
and nine
yeah
three six nine
locker
locker locker locker
three six nine
damn girl fine
oh i'm shaking and crying right now
please no
i'm crying and
shaking rn
take it
cut off
your leg
it's the only way
cut your leg off with the saw
i saw this in a movie once i can't
remember the name though
look around take in the
giver gander
keep th peep that body yo
47k huh this is a pretty potent stream
hmm
there's only one solution to this hmm
couldn't possibly be
no
it can't be
i'm shaking
and crying rn
what if you have to use the saw to cut
off the hand
oh god no
i didn't want
this i'm shaking and crying rn
are you shaking and crying rn because i
am shaking and crying
all right
wow
the hand back on the body
no
this is
this is gonna go well this is gonna be
good aha
i knew it i'm so excited
i'm
shaking and crying rn slap it put your
dick in the scanner
hand me
this is the biggest stream on the site
right now hell yeah hell yeah it is well
it's dark here
well this probably isn't gonna go good
for me
or you specifically i'm fine this
definitely oh
yep
who called it
ow
how
oh i definitely saw this in a movie one
time duck
duck
cut your hand off
it's the only way i'm shaking and crying
use the saw
saw your handles or duck
you seem to be shaking and crying rn
oh man
i knew oh wait people are leaving the
stream why
but why though
oh
yeah hey what the [ __ ] no please
i'm shaking and crying
oh
hello
watch them suffer watch them oh
i am
hello
lovely day we're having punch
all right fine
[Music]
i love that i loved that i thought that
was really really cool it's such a
wonderful little mixture
of like old school
like text adventure stuff very simple
stuff and yet putting it in a way that's
completely novel and topical oh i got
one star what does that even mean i bet
there are easter eggs ooh i bet there
are easter eggs hang on i want to see
something if i go
peep
poop
like
shaking
crying is six or six
a seven seven seven
well sorry lord shaken crying seven
seven seven age seven
uh
lord shaken
shaken crying seven sevens
lord shaken crying lord shaken kern
seven seven
lord shirk and kern seven
i'm 77
7. all right epic jake
oh come on oh come on
no
i was hoping no come on
no please
i want the korean one
no
goodbye all right fine i guess that's
all
or is it because this person actually
made another
game called feed vid
sound familiar
it might be
okay okay
what does puzzle mode mean
play feed vid without over scares nah
what's that all about ooh it's
oh yeah
hidden messages wow the issue is with
this series that we clearly see evidence
of coal guards having the power if their
civilization fell before the sentinels i
don't know what that is
funny wink app
this is actually cringe colleges are a
front for gender studies mafia
feminist lectures
take a break
that's cute
epic challenge for you
no more videos ah vid0001
oh
i see
well this is suspicious
it's a long hallway
oh
that's weird
what the [ __ ]
is this
i'm shook
and possibly
crying
we are watching you oh
my merch so scary
videos are more entertaining than the
actual game
huh
interesting
is there something that i have to
comment
[Music]
i see
what was that
interesting i love that it also has
three bad horror games
wow
[Music]
oh
okay
ah interesting
[Music]
interesting need door code
uh
do you now
seven three nine five got it
seven three nine five
oh yeah
epic zombie swarm my friend told me
there's a secret code where you can get
unlimited ammo he said it was something
like up
right down or something i forgot
okay
up right down got it up right down i bet
that's a map up right down
i bet this is a map
any direction for vents
do you
i might know exactly where you need to
go
so
i got it you need to go up right down up
right
down right right up up left up up up
right down
right right up up
left up up
up right down right right up up left up
up
two hours of a black screen
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
that's only 10 minutes
i didn't i didn't know that it would
actually be a video
i didn't
okay well i don't have time for that
arnie is evil
is arnie evil wham
there's probably a secret if you do the
likes and dislikes oh
stay away from arnie
oh
i'm scared 1203.
yeah what happens if you like and
dislike some of these videos
need another door code i see
okay
so what could this be for
went to class neural net robot dreams
1.8 million views six views
so i'm scared at 12.03
super easy one 203.
wow
it's done
what's done what did you do
oh
that's a brain those are brains i'm
shaking and crying rn
oh
i guess i never really thought
that what i was doing would have been
wrong
the repercussions of my actions were not
at the forefront of my mind
when i went into it
i just thought that maybe i was having a
fun time that i was special because my
recommended video showed me something
that no one else saw
and that i was the only one that could
help
i just wanted to feel important
and yet although those brains got
smashed to bits
i guess i regret it
[Music]
oh
anyway maybe i'll go over to twitch
youtube videos are a little too extreme
for me
i like that i did like that i think the
twitch one works uh better with the
interactive but this still worked great
i if even if this one was fleshed out it
will be great i don't want to like
compare it to be like once better than
the other because this also has like
such a unique thing and it reminds me of
that game that was all from your phone i
forget what it's called but it was just
like a horror game that was all about
like looking up stuff on your phone
very cool
i like both of these a lot
great stuff
fantastic
really cool
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know damn that do you
thought
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below and if you find an easter
egg like something you type into this
that's unique and i bet there is i can't
imagine there wouldn't be and if there
isn't then the developer needs to put
one in somewhere
so
yeah
oh thanks for playing
oh
thanks playing feed it what is what's
this
oh my god i'm such a fan
i'm shaking and crying
right now rn
thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
oh p.s uh as you're watching this write
in the comments uh to control my actions
and tell me what to do cool gotcha thank
you bye
[Music]